[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat et de reportage sur
Public Sénat tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h on donne du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et ce
soir en pleine réforme des retraites
c'est une émission spéciale que je vous
propose sur la valeur travail est-elle
en perdition percutée par la crise covid
le télétravail mais aussi par celles et
ceux qui revendiquent haut et fort à la
tribune de l'Assemblée le droit à la
paresse ne vous empêcher
ons d'autres jours d'accaparer notre
bien
Paul parce qu'elle permettait de
contraindre les bourgeois
tu recommences
[Applaudissements]
oui endroit à la retraite à 60 ans
quelle réponse les politiques et les
entreprises doivent-ils apporter à la
quête de sens réclamée par de plus en
plus de salariés c'est ce que nous
verrons dans notre premier débat et puis
juste après on va comparer notre système
de retraite à celui de nos voisins voir
comment des journalistes européens une
Allemande un Italien une portugaise
analyse la place du travail et des
loisirs dans la société française mais
d'abord cette question la France
est-elle frappée par une épidémie de
flemme à lire l'étude publiée au mois de
novembre par l'Ifop et la Fondation Jean
Jaurès la réponse est plutôt oui Hugo
Lemonnier le travail une valeur de moins
en moins investie par les Français en
1990 60% des sons des considérés le
travail très important ils ne sont plus
que 24% en 2022 d'après une étude de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès c'est une erreur
de dire que les Français ne veulent plus
y a fortiorer les jeunes ne veulent plus
travailler tout le monde a besoin de
travailler mais l'emploi et moins envie
tel qu'il se présente actuellement c'est
à vous avez beaucoup de jeunes qui
arrivent sur le marché du travail qui
ont vu leurs parents qui ont vu leurs
proches travailler beaucoup sans être
forcément reconnu qui ont vu des
générations galérées pouvant se
retrouver du jour au lendemain au
chômage et qui n'ont pas forcément envie
de faire les mêmes entre guillemets
sacrifices par rapport à ça si les
formes de pénibilité au travail varient
selon les classes sociales les salariés
qu'ils soient cadres ouvriers ou
employés parlent tous d'un même manque
de reconnaissance et quand on parle de
reconnaissance il y a la rémunération
mais il y a pas que la rémunération
c'est souvent vous êtes souvent
confronté à un management vertical avec
cette culture de plutôt voir quand les
choses vont pas forcément bien sans dire
qu'on les choses vont bien et puis vous
avez aussi quel que soit là aussi votre
que vous soyez cadre vous voyez employé
le sentiment que vous ne pouvez pas
suffisamment vous projeter dans votre
entreprise c'est-à-dire vos perspectives
d'évolution en interne sont pas assez
importantes à ces tendances s'ajoutent
pour les jeunes diplômés une quête de
sens à laquelle le marché du travail
semble avoir du mal à répondre vous ne
pouvez plus aujourd'hui rec Ruter un
cadre de -35 ans uniquement sur des
aspects sur des aspects traditionnels de
salaires ou de place dans la hiérarchie
c'est l'entreprise aussi qui sera
investie sur tous ces enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux qui sera davantage qui
sera davantage choisi c'est
transformations du rapport au travail ne
s'accompagne pas pour autant d'une
grande vague de démission si une
majorité des sondées envisagées de
quitter leur emploi afin de 2022 seul
2,7% des salariés à sauter le pas
je représente tout de suite les invités
de ce premier débat Chloé Morin bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes politologue
auteur de ce livre On a tout essayé qui
vient de sortir aux éditions Fayard
après le succès de votre précédente
ouvrage on a les politiques combérites
qui étaient sortis l'an dernier Michael
Zemmour bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes enseignants chercheurs au
centre d'économie de la Sorbonne
université parisien j'accue également
Jean-Marc Daniel bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes économiste Emily
zappalski bonsoir bienvenue spécialiste
en communication publique et
éditorialiste pour sens public cette
semaine Chloé Morin est-ce que vous
reprenez à votre compte l'expression de
cette étude de l'ifope et de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès que vous
connaissez évidemment très bien la
France frappée par une épidémie de
flemme
je pense que le rapport au travail
change clairement après une épidémie de
flemme ça c'est porter un jugement un
peu négatif sur sur des tendances qui
sont qui sont profondes et qui me
semblent justifier la transformation de
notre rapport au travail ça me semble
pour le coup pas nécessairement négatif
donc oui mais c'était très bien dit dans
votre dans votre sujet en gros ce qui ce
qui se passe c'est la les gens
réordonnent leur priorité c'est pas
seulement que que le travail
enfin qui n'ont plus envie de travailler
c'est surtout que en fait par rapport à
l'ensemble de ce qui fait l'équilibre
d'une vie il repense il repense les
choses et c'est surtout d'ailleurs sans
doute les jeunes générations c'est ce
qui est frappant c'est que l'idéal en
fait qui a été
celui de pas mal de générations de du
cadre qui travaille très dur qui ou en
fait celui qui fait le plus d'heures
possible au bureau qui arrive très tôt
qui repart très tard qui travaille le
week-end tout ça ça n'est plus un idéal
de vie et quelque part quand on voit les
excès que ça a comportait c'est
peut-être pas si mal sans nécessairement
tomber dans l'excellent inverse qui est
plus personne veut travailler quoi
Michael Zemmour le moi en vous entendant
je pense notamment à la représentante
des internes qui est venu ici parler du
de son côté médecin et dire que voilà ça
les internes français aujourd'hui dans
leur grande majorité ils veulent plus du
tout pratiquer leur art comme leurs
parents ou même encore plus leurs
grands-parents le faisait on voit il y a
effectivement des étudiants de grandes
écoles de l'université aussi mais quels
éléments qui ont exprimé ça à la remise
des diplômes est-ce que c'est
générationnel ou est-ce que c'est plus
profond que ça je sais pas il y a sans
doute des choses différentes quand vous
parlez des internes il y a une il y a
sans doute une question de genre ce qui
explique les vieux internes en disant
nous on fonctionnait pas comme ça
c'était des qui avait à domicile des
personnes qui étaient moins en emploi ou
pas en emploi et qui s'occupait de la
maison et aujourd'hui à l'hôpital où les
professions médicales elles expliquent
qu'elles ont un travail et une vie
privée et qu'elle voit faire les deux ça
c'est une première chose puis il y a la
question du sens dont vous parlez qui
est important je pense que dans les
années 80 90 il y avait le capitalisme
en lui-même fournissait son propre sens
c'est à dire que la réussite de
l'entreprise c'était un objectif et
qu'aujourd'hui il a pas vraiment de
proposition sociale économique à faire
et que en revanche des choses qui
apparaissent importantes et notamment
l'urgence climatique mais aussi les
objectifs sociaux sont au cœur des
préoccupations des diplômés et donc ils
sont pas simplement dans la réussite de
l'entreprise mais ils cherchent à
travailler pour quelque chose et je
pense que c'est de ça dont on entend
parler
j'aimerais Daniel je reprends le mot
flemme même si on va pas faire toutes
les missions là-dessus
c'est de la flemme c'est de la fatigue
accumulée face aux crises comme vous
vous analysez vous non je pense pas que
ce soit de la flemme les les
il y a jamais eu autant de gens qui
étaient au travail que dans ce pays et
on dit depuis plusieurs générations mais
il faut bien voir on parle des années 80
mais dans les années 1950 d'abord on
travaille beaucoup plus mais surtout les
le travail c'était du travail agricole
et du travail ouvrier maintenant le
travail il y a plus d'agriculteurs il y
a 400000 exploitations agricoles il y a
3 fois moins que les années 70 il y a 3
millions d'ouvriers alors que encore en
1975 il y avait 6 millions d'ouvriers
donc le travail a changé complètement de
nature et à partir de ce moment-là il y
a des modes d'organisation de réflexion
de rapport au travail tu as changé le le
le syndicalisme n'est plus le même dans
un monde ouvrier que et dans un monde de
cadre mais là il y a eu un effet
d'accélération quand même
qui a peut-être surpris à tort mais qui
a quand même sur la deuxième chose c'est
que je pense qu'effectivement on assiste
à une mutation du travail avec trois
éléments qui jouent d'abord
effectivement le covid a montré que le
télétravail pouvait être un moyen de
s'organiser le deuxième enjeu c'est
qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'auto-entrepreneurs et des
auto-entrepreneurs c'est pas uniquement
des gens qui part la retraite ou des
gens qui font un complément de salaire
au travers des auto-entrepreneuriat
c'est effectivement un mode
d'organisation et un certain nombre de
gens se disent mon dieu c'est pas
forcément désagréable d'avoir une
certaine forme d'autonomie on voit bien
en Californie ou on a voulu requalifier
les auto-entrepreneurs l'équivalent en
salariés c'est la population elle-même
qui a dit non on veut garder cette
autonomie cette forme d'organisation et
le troisième élément je pense c'est que
par rapport aux années il y avait des
alors il y avait une contestation de
travail il y avait une contestation du
capitalisme et il y avait des lieux où
on pouvait dire on vit mieux on a ces
débarrassé du capitalisme le message des
années 70-80 en mai 68 il y avait des
gens qui pensaient qu'en Chine on vivait
beaucoup mieux qu'en France et donc on
pouvait organiser différemment le
travail il y a des gens qui ont écouté
vous allez au Cambodge de polpote et on
vit beaucoup mieux sauf que maintenant
on sait que au Cambodge ne pas le poète
on vivait nettement moins bien que
maintenant les dents je rejoins Mickaël
c'est-à-dire que les enjeux et les
espoirs ne sont plus sur l'organisation
du travail mais c'est sûr la réponse au
problème climatique la réponse au
problème et énergétique sentez plus la
réponse à l'organisation du travail oui
mais Michael Zemmour il peut les espoirs
ils peuvent être dans l'entreprise
paradoxalement quand on étudie le niveau
de confiance des Français dans leur les
institutions générales l'entreprise
arrive quasiment en première position
oui oui je pense que ça peut sembler à
contradictoire d'abord les entreprises
ça dépend il y a des métiers qui sont
des métiers de pure exécution où on
vient on fait 16 heures et où il y a pas
de sens particulier si ce n'est le
travail bien fait et puis il y en a ou
des postes où on peut avoir un sens plus
particulier mais il y a aussi une
question de reconnaissance on est dans
une période où le chômage baisse quand
le chômage baisse traditionnellement on
est plus exigeant et on est exigeant sur
quoi soit sur la capacité à décider ce
sur quoi on travaille soit sur son temps
de travail soit sur la rémunération la
rémunération ça bouge pas les jeunes qui
sont embauchés aujourd'hui sont
embauchés à des salaires inférieurs aux
jeunes embauchés il y a 10 ans
sur le temps de travail ça peut être
justement une aspiration avoir du temps
libéré et sur le fait de décider ce
qu'on fait effectivement apparemment
quand on fait des comparaisons
internationales il y a d'autres pays où
les salariés sont davantage associés à
l'organisation du travail ou au projet
de l'entreprise qu'en France
d'une manière assez positive parce que
je me dis bah c'est forcément pour aller
dans du sens dans du bien-être aussi
dans du mieux travailler peut-être aussi
avec plus d'autonomie et peut-être des
tâches à l'objectif et pas forcément
autant rester parce qu'on se souvient de
il faut rester le plus longtemps
possible pour être bien vu et pour bien
travailler soi-disant mais maintenant il
y a besoin d'adaptation et c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que les entreprises
elles sont allées vers le télétravail à
reculons et c'est vrai que le covid a
accéléré les choses et on voit bien que
les salariés en ont envie et que ça
fonctionne simplement c'est un mode de
management qui est complètement
différent il faut complètement changer
tout ça et vous parliez
d'auto-entrepreneur oui il y a des
auto-entrepreneurs mais on est quand
même une France beaucoup plus de
salariés on a encore du mal à s'adapter
à ça je prends juste un exemple pendant
la crise covid au début on leur donnait
1500 euros par mois aux entrepreneur ça
voulait dire vous savez le fond de
solidarité c'était quand même un peu mec
ça veut dire qu'on peut pas imaginer que
des auto-entrepreneurs gagnent mieux
c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui gagnent pas
beaucoup mais il y a des créateurs
d'entreprises qui ont pas forcément de
salariés mais qui gagnent aussi et ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est à la
fois au sein des entreprises et au sein
de l'État il y a un grand bouleversement
à avoir une grande adaptation à ces
nouveaux modes de travail et de
conditions de travail qui sont demandées
surtout par les jeunes faire une réforme
des retraites basées sur l'allongement
de l'âge de départ au moment justement
où les Français se posent des questions
sur sur le sens du travail est-ce que
c'est pas un contre-sens politiques mais
c'est tout le problème effectivement il
y a deux problèmes en fait dans cette
réforme des retraites il y a un au-delà
de ce qu'on peut penser de l'option qui
consiste à allonger l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est le premier élément c'est
qu'en fait on a fait tellement de
réforme des retraites que les gens se
disent au fond même avec cette réforme
qui nous demande des efforts importants
on aura toujours pas réglé le problème
et on va revenir dans deux ans trois ans
10 ans pour nous dire qu'il faut à
nouveau faire de nouveaux efforts donc
il y a ce sentiment que le sujet n'est
jamais réglé et qu'au fond on fait des
efforts en vain donc ça c'est une
première chose et la deuxième chose
effectivement c'est que au moment même
où une partie de la population est en
train de repenser son rapport au travail
ou voir exprime une souffrance au
travail
en leur demande de travailler plus
forcément c'est ça passe assez mal donc
le
gouvernement aurait sans doute dû poser
la question du travail
avant de poser la question des retraites
une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est très
compliqué parce que tous les sujets dont
on a parlé aujourd'hui c'est des sujets
qui dont les politiques ont du mal à
s'emparer c'est à dire qu'ils parlent de
valeur travail
il parle à la limite de durée tu
travailles mais lorsqu'on parle de
management d'autonomie d'équilibre entre
vie perso et c'est des choses qui
peuvent se gérer que dans les
entreprises et donc le politique est un
peu
impuissant en fait n'arrive pas à avoir
prise sur ces éléments là et quand on
parle de culture managériale par exemple
bah c'est pas le ministre du Travail qui
décrète la manière dont une entreprise
versée salariés
est-ce que un pays qui travaille moins
c'est forcément un pays qui saute ah oui
je pense que c'est un pays qui
s'appauvri parce que la richesse c'est
quoi c'est de la quantité de travail
multiplié par la qualité du travail et
donc jusqu'à présent on a pu baisser la
quantité de travail parce qu'on a
amélioré en permanence l'efficacité du
travail ce qu'on appelle la productivité
en ce moment alors il y a des rapports
il y a même un rapport qui avait été
demandé par le précédent gouvernement
qui avait conclu au fait que l'évolution
de la productivité était un mystère
mais mystère négatif c'est à dire que la
productivité n'augmente plus
l'efficacité n'augmente plus et même
dans certains pays elle recule comme en
Italie on se pose la question de savoir
si en France on va pas être bientôt dans
cette situation donc il y a pas d'autres
choix que de travailler plus si je joue
aussi
la démonstration exactement en termes de
bouclage macroéconomique de la même
situation 82 83 un déficit extérieur
considérable ce qui veut dire que le
revenu qui distribué à la population est
supérieure à la production réalisée par
cette population et donc si on veut
équilibrer nos comptes on a que deux
solutions soit on augmente la production
soit on baisse le revenu en 82 83 on a
choisi de baisser le revenu je rappelle
quand même que en 82 83 la politique de
rigueur ça consistait à baisser le
revenu c'est le revenu la baisse de
revenus la plus spectaculaire qu'on a
connue depuis la Libération et a lieu à
83 bon donc c'est pas exactement ce
verre pas en souriante donc l'autre
solution c'est d'augmenter la quantité
de travail alors augmenter la quantité
de travail c'est en ça que le message du
gouvernement est ambigu c'est à dire que
dans ses vœux le président de la
République dit travail engagement et ça
se traduit par rapport de l'âge de
départ la retraite mais le CD dans son
dernier rapport sur la France dit
effectivement il faut augmenter la
quantité de travail mais il est probable
qu'il vaut mieux supprimer des jours de
congés que de reporter là je devais pas
parce que entre 60 et 64 ans normalement
les gens sont moins efficaces même si on
reste quand même dynamique entre 60 et
64 ans alors que si on supprime des
jours de fériés on va faire travailler
des gens qui ont entre 25 et 50 ans qui
sont au milieu de leur capacité et donc
effectivement le choix je pense pour la
France c'est soit on baisse le revenu
soit on augmente la quantité de travail
soit on continue dans l'illusion
actuelle qui consiste à faire payer nos
importations par les exportations
allemandes parce que pourquoi on n'est
pas en 83 pourquoi on n'a pas la
nécessité de 83 c'est que il y a une
illusion qui entretenue par la zone euro
ce qui nous manque c'est les Allemands
qui nous l'apportent alors on va y
revenir évidemment mais vous allez faire
allusion au vœu d'Emmanuel Macron Émilie
vous avez pour évaluer l'utilisation du
mot travail par le Président de la
République vous allez sortir la
calculette oui j'ai sorti à calculette
et j'ai vu que c'était presque 20 fois
un 17 fois travail ou travailler on
avait ça dans les vœux d'Emmanuel Macron
comme vous l'avez souligné et si on
l'écoutait vraiment tout serait réglé
parce que vous avez repris comme
expression par notre travail et par
notre engagement je vous propose de
l'écouter justement à ce sujet je nous
souhaite pour 2023 par notre travail et
notre engagement devrait à refonder une
France plus forte plus juste pour la
transmettre à nos enfants
c'est par notre travail et notre
engagement que nous pourrons augmenter
les moyens des forces de sécurité
intérieure de notre justice de nos
armées face aux nouveaux défis
géopolitiques et à la multiplication des
conflits c'est par notre travail et
notre engagement que nous bâtirons aussi
une nation productive et écologique
c'est par notre travail et notre
engagement que nous resterons aussi une
nation de confiance
alors vous avez compris le principe ça
se décliner un petit peu comme ça à
l'infini une rhétorique était qui a
beaucoup d'accents Sarkozy star on se
souvient de cette valeur travail et
cette rhétorique autour du travail a été
réutilisée par le Président de la
République récemment lors de son premier
déplacement sur le sol français puisque
jusqu'à maintenant c'est vrai qu'il nous
parlait plutôt de l'étranger de la
réforme des retraites et de tout autre
chose et pour se déplacement il avait
choisi Rungis alors c'est pas par hasard
non plus c'est la France de ceux qui se
lèvent tôt pour travailler et c'était
aussi la petite chanson de Sarkozy et le
même lieu qu'il avait utilisé en 2007
dans le cadre de sa campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle alors pour
Emmanuel Macron il l'a rappelé lors de
ce déplacement il faut travailler plus
longtemps parce qu'on vit plus âgé pour
créer plus de richesses pour le pays
pour réindustrialiser le pays pour
financer l'éducation la santé je vous
refais pas la liste parce que on est
toujours dans ce même et pour être tout
à fait juste c'est vrai que c'est quand
même une valeur et une rhétorique que
Emmanuel Macron avait utilisé depuis
longtemps depuis le début de sa
candidature en 2017 il était sur cette
idée de d'être le candidat du travail
mais là il insiste lourdement pourquoi
il insiste maintenant sur la valeur
travail alors la rhétorique est pas
choisi par hasard le moment est clé pour
la réforme des retraites puisque
évidemment après une pause parlementaire
on a fini le passage à l'Assemblée
nationale on arrive au Sénat qui est
majoritairement de droite et le travail
forcément c'est une valeur qui parle à
la droite les républicains qui sont
majoritaires au Sénat ont d'ailleurs
toujours défendu le report de l'âge
légal à la retraite à 64 ans alors
l'objectif de ces communications qui
sont légèrement appuyées si vous me
permettez c'est clair c'est de se
rapprocher et de séduire cette droite
qui permettrait aux projets de loi
d'être voté au Sénat pour oublier toute
la cacophonie sans vote qui se tenait à
l'Assemblée nationale jusqu'au 17
devriez et les ministres n'ont pas
hésité en rajouter une couche en forçant
le trait ces dernières semaines la palme
revenant à Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur qu'il attaque l'opposition
Monsieur Mélenchon et ses amis défendent
le lit des gauchistes bobos celles d'une
société sans travail sans effort dit-il
dénonçant la négation du travail et le
droit à la paresse qui était soutenu
comme l'a entendu tout à l'heure par
Sandrine Rousseau donc d'un côté on
frappe fort avec le travail mais de
l'autre on caresse comment alors parce
que l'idée du gouvernement c'est petit à
petit après le projet de retraite de
réforme sur les retraites qui agit
toujours beaucoup et qui est toujours
très peu soutenu par l'opinion publique
les syndicats et même les travailleurs
qui se lèvent tôt parce qu'ils étaient
aussi dans les rangs des manifestations
et bien l'idée c'est de passer à du
sucré après alors je vous explique en
fait c'est l'idée d'un projet de loi
pleine emploi qui viendrait à la suite
du projet de réforme des retraites et
qui serait voté peut-être avant l'été et
qui parlerait semaine de quatre jours
qualité de vie au travail et même
généralisation rendez compte épargne
tant pour aménager son temps de travail
sur l'année et bizarrement ça c'est un
souhait de la CFDT depuis très longtemps
donc on voit qu'il y a l'envie de
renouer les liens mais le problème c'est
qu'au Sénat les républicains sont
commencés ont commencé à monter en
puissance pour faire une réforme des
retraites beaucoup plus durs avec
notamment l'accélération de la fin des
régimes spéciaux et ça ça peut agiter
fortement ou en tout cas relancer la
machine des mobilisations et on entend
déjà parler d'une grève reconductible
qui a été annoncée par les syndicats de
la SNCF après le 7 mars jour d'arrêt de
la France alors pas sûr que ce projet de
loi pleine emploi un peu sucré puisse
calmer les ardeurs des mobilisations et
Michael Zemmour c'est je reprends le la
sortie de du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin et le fait que
finalement
on va dire la partie droite de du
pouvoir macroniste mais c'est pas
seulement ça c'est aussi la majorité LR
ici au Sénat ou des députés LR à
l'Assemblée même si ils ont parfois
sembler un peu à contre emploi eux aussi
il y a cette façon de
j'allais dire s'accaparer la valeur
travail c'est pas forcément
historiquement c'était pas forcément une
valeur de droite la valeur travail
pour moi enfin je suis désolé mais c'est
surtout de la diversion un peu politique
ça parle pas des enjeux et le rapport au
travail dans la réforme des retraites
d'abord il faut le distinguer selon les
publics et les situations mais c'est pas
le même pour tout le monde d'abord il y
a une première pour moi c'est la
question peut-être la plus importante
qui est posée c'est travailler jusqu'à
l'âge de la retraite et aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas et vous avez
à peu près 25% des gens qui finissent
leur carrière au chômage en inactivité
ou en invalidité et on sait que quand on
décale la retraite on va avoir à peu
près peut-être 300 000 personnes en plus
en emploi mais à peu près 150 à 200 000
personnes en plus au chômage ou au RSA
et donc la première question que pose la
question des retraites c'est les
personnes qui sont hors de l'emploi
parce que soit elles ont été licenciés
soit parce qu'on ne les a plus embaucher
à cette période là donc là le ministre
intérieur parle complètement à côté de
ce sujet là puis le deuxième sujet et ça
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure c'est
la souffrance au travail c'est à dire
que on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de
métiers particulièrement en France mais
pas que en France qui sont pénibles dont
la pénibilité n'est pas reconnue
physiquement ou en termes de stress et
on sait qu'une longue exposition à ces
facteurs de pénibilité aggravent les
conséquences sur la santé surtout à ses
âges et donc les personnes souhaitent
pouvoir s'arrêter avant d'être trop
abîmé et puis enfin il y a une troisième
question qui est importante aussi c'est
quel est le sens de la retraite est-ce
que passer un certain âge parce qu'on
reconnaît la valeur du travail qui a été
accompli on a le droit à un temps libéré
et donc de disposer de sa vie d'avoir un
activité associative des loisirs etc ou
alors est-ce que la retraite c'est
uniquement le moment où parce qu'on ne
peut plus rien faire d'autre on vous
sort du marché du travail et donc c'est
une troisième question et il me semble
que le ministre de l'Intérieur est à
côté de ces trois questions qui sont les
questions posées par la réforme et
d'ailleurs c'est la même question de
poser à Chloé Morin tout à l'heure c'est
à dire que avant de lancer la réforme
des retraites il fallait peut-être poser
ces enjeux là notamment l'emploi des
seniors ce qui est terrible c'est que la
question de l'emploi des seniors on en
reparle à chaque réforme des retraites
un peu comme alibi en disant on voit
bien qu'il y a un problème mais on va le
régler or il y a de problème d'abord
toutes les mesures sur l'emploi des
seigneurs qui ont été mises dans la loi
on sait maintenant que il y a un fort
risque d'inconstitutionnalité et qu'elle
risque de disparaître du texte donc
c'est un peu des mesures alibi et
ensuite combien même on pense que ces
mesures auraient de l'effet ce qui est
pas vraiment certain parce qu'elles sont
très légères elles concerneront les
personnes dans 10 ans donc les premières
personnes qui vont être concernées par
la réforme celle qu'on 55 ans ou plus et
qui se demande comment elles vont tenir
ou qui sont déjà hors de l'emploi elle
de toute façon la question est déjà
réglée et donc on va leur compliquer la
tâche alors même qu'il y a pas de
solution un témoignage je pense que vous
allez me suivre en régie c'était pas ce
qui était prévu mais j'aurais qu'on
parle de l'emploi des seniors donc je
vous propose un témoignage sur ce thème
c'est une directrice financière qui
cherche un emploi elle s'appelle
Delphine elle a pas elle a passé voilà
le stade fatidique entre guillemets des
55 ans on l'écoute j'ai 56 ans et je
ressens parfaitement que ça c'est un
frein parce que beaucoup d'entreprises
enfin beaucoup quelques entreprises
m'ont dit mais combien de temps
allez-vous rester chez nous vous voyez
ils ont peur en fait que je m'en aille
au bout de trois quatre ans alors que
souvent c'est le fait des plus jeunes
qui eux n'hésitent pas à bouger moi à
mon âge j'ai envie de dire je reste
jusqu'à ce que Monsieur Macron nous dise
qu'on peut partir à la retraite
Jean-Marc Daniel votre avis sur le
l'emploi des des seniors est-ce que
alors j'ai bien entendu vos chiffres
mais est-ce que ce serait pas aussi un
moyen de rééquilibrer le système de
répartition de mettre de plus de gens à
l'emploi en réformant l'emploi des
seniors oui c'est évident qu'un des
enjeux et de la de l'ensemble des
mesures qui sont prises c'est
d'augmenter le taux d'emploi y compris
des seniors d'ailleurs quand on regarde
la retraite à 60 ans c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure dans le couloir
alors j'aime bien quand on partage avec
avec les téléspectateurs ce qui s'est
dit avant dans le couloir super allez-y
en fait quand on regarde le discours de
François Mitterrand à l'époque il y
avait une partie disait bon les
travailleurs ont le droit enfin un
discours classique et puis il disait
deux choses importantes il disait en
fait on a mis tellement de préretraite
il y a tellement du genre qui entre 60
et 65 ans sont payés en pré-retraite
donc son pays à ne rien faire on a
plutôt été à les mettre à la retraite
parce qu'une retraite coûte moins cher
que une pré-retraite et donc c'est une
façon d'une certaine économiser et la
deuxième chose qu'il disait s'il y a un
problème de chômage c'est ça le vrai
problème qu'il faut résoudre et donc
disait-il quand le baby-boom arrivera à
l'âge de la retraite quand les gens ont
mis en 1946 arriveront à l'année donc en
2006 disait-il on aura résolu le
problème du chômage et à partir du
moment là on pourra reporter là je
faisais par la retraite le ramener à 65
ans parce que le système ne supportera
pas la mise à la retraite à 60 ans du
baby boom bon alors le problème c'est
que effectivement on a toujours pas
résolu le problème du chômage même si la
situation s'améliore le chômage baisse
mais il y a quand même encore 2 millions
800 000 dans ce pays c'est énorme et
donc la politique du gouvernement c'est
quand même aussi de dire on réforme
l'assurance chômage pour essayer aussi
d'inciter la population à revenir vers
le travail on réduit la durée
d'indemnisation pour essayer de
mobiliser l'emploi donc toutes ces
stratégies c'est plus une stratégie de
croissance retour à l'emploi
valorisation du travail que
véritablement une stratégie de droit à
l'appareil de à partir d'un constat je
maintiens c'est que le pays vit
au-dessus de ses moyens c'est-à-dire que
on ne peut pas durablement accumuler les
déficits que nous accumulons en ce
moment mais juste en termes de
communication c'est un peu un dialogue
de sourd parce que on comprend très bien
ce que vous dites mais c'est et c'est
dit un petit peu comme ça par le
gouvernement avec un tableur XL si vous
voulez et en face on a des des envies
d'une société qui qui change auquel on
répond pas finalement alors qu'on
pourrait se dire que c'est un projet
collectif parce que comme vous le dites
plus on travaille plus on va avoir de
richesses plus on peut se la partager et
plus on a un pays qui économiquement et
sain mais c'est pas du tout l'accent qui
est mis en terme de communication par le
gouv simplement donc il y a un peu un
dialogue de sourd qui qui a du mal à
aboutir ce qui me frappe dans ce c'est à
quel point finalement
on interroge même plus les codes qui
sont des codes de communication et qui
ont été posées effectivement par Nicolas
Sarkozy notamment pendant sa campagne
présidentielle en 2016 quand il dit va
leur travail parce que valeur ça veut
dire ça renvoie en fait une forme
d'impératif moral et ça renvoie aussi à
une sorte de tripartition de la société
entre les les assister
ceux qui travaillent qui sont méritants
etc et les assister du haut c'est à dire
les plus riches qui se soustrait à la
solidarité alors de voir de solidarité
nationale etc et les plus pauvres en
fait ou les chômeurs
dont on dit c'était c'est le discours
d'une partie de la droite dont on dit
qu'ils sont responsables de leur
situation de chômage et qui sont
feignants etc et qui ne veulent pas
retourner en emploi et quelque part il y
a quand même la manière de faire
référence à la valeur travail ça permet
d'évacuer dans les représentations
toutes les questions notamment de
pénibilité de souffrance au travail les
questions de de des causes du chômage
qui sont autre que la simple volonté du
voilà et donc ça permet en fait
d'orienter tout le débat il est
représentations des gens mais je reste
avec vous parce que toujours sur le
l'emploi des seniors le fait que
finalement bon la France reste on le
verra aussi dans notre seconde partie
d'émission mais plutôt à la traîne des
autres pays européens donc un constat
d'impuissance des pouvoirs politiques
qui se sont succédés c'est au cœur de
votre livre cette ce sentiment
d'impuissance est-ce que là aussi c'est
parce que finalement ça repousse pas
plus sur
une culture d'entreprise ou des ou des
ou des mauvaises habitudes prises par
des des recruteurs ou des DRH
sur la manière sur l'incapacité de la
France à mieux employer ces seniors
pour le couple il y a un vrai sujet
d'ailleurs pour pour mon livre j'ai
interrogé notamment des responsables
syndicaux et ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
frappé c'est que que ce soit Philippe
Martinez ou Laurent Berger par exemple
disent la classe politique française a
en moyenne une méconnaissance profonde
du monde de l'entreprise et du monde des
salariés et de ce qu'est l'expérience du
travail et alors évidemment c'est en
moyenne parce qu'il y a forcément et moi
j'en ai croisé plein des responsables
politiques qui ont été avant
entrepreneurs qui ont été plein de
choses mais
sans doute que dans la manière dont on a
appréhendé la question du travail et
notamment du travail des seniors puisque
c'est votre question depuis
20 30 40 ans il y a sans doute quelque
part
de cette méconnaissance là
de la part de tes responsables
politiques
et donc que ça imprégné quelque part les
solutions qui ont été mises en oeuvre et
y compris la manière dont on écoute ou
pas les experts des différents sujets
pour éclairer le débat je voudrais qu'on
parle maintenant du télétravail la crise
covid les confinements ont évidemment
provoqué ce questionnement sur la place
au Bureau 33% des actifs télétravail au
moins un jour par semaine aujourd'hui il
n'était que 3% en 2017 ça donne une idée
de l'accélération du du phénomène et je
vous propose un témoignage un exemple
celui de Brice Amato il est responsable
d'études marketing il a aménagé sa
chambre d'amis en bureau regardez
voilà donc ici c'est mon espace de
télétravail donc à la base c'était une
chambre d'amis
mais vu que le télétravail s'instaure
régulièrement pour moi pour
m'accompagner aussi on avait besoin
d'avoir vraiment une espace au calme et
dédié à l'activité de télétravail cette
flexibilité c'est ce système un peu
hybride
et justement je trouve un très bon moyen
pour pour pouvoir réaliser tous les
missions qu'on a à faire chaque jour ou
tout au long de la semaine ça change la
vie
il y a pour moi vraiment plein
d'avantages
au-delà du confort et du calme qu'on
peut avoir dans son bureau chez soi
plutôt qu'au bureau en entreprise moi
l'avantage numéro un c'est le la fatigue
en moins liée au transport le plan de
coupe sur la piscine qui vous évite ça
vous guérir sur les avantages mais
au-delà de l'anecdote est-ce que c'est
pas aussi une une fracture entre
Français parce qu'il y a ceux qui
peuvent télétravailler et puis à ceux ou
pour qui c'est un ça n'arrivera jamais
quoi tout simplement bien sûr il y a
plein d'emplois qui ne sont pas
télétravables dans la logistique dans le
nettoyage chez les ouvrières les
ouvriers etc et c'est à la fois les
métiers où il est le plus dur de trouver
à l'approche de la retraite un emploi de
se faire réembaucher et c'est là où il y
a aussi le plus de pénibilité non
reconnu et donc effectivement parmi les
facteurs de pénibilité passé 55 60 ans
avoir un temps de transport que ça soit
en transport en commun ou automobile
très long c'est un facteur j'ai envie de
dire de d'inégalités qui redouble c'est
à dire qu'à la fin on sait que la
réforme des retraites pas davantage
toucher les personnes qui ont commencé
autour d'une vingtaine d'années un peu
moins les personnes qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études et en même temps c'est
les mêmes personnes qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études qui peuvent par
exemple accéder au télétravail et
aménager leur temps et l'organisation de
leur travail et donc du coup la réforme
elle est ressentie d'autant plus
durement que cette question de des
conditions de travail mais aussi des
conditions de transport
se posent pour des personnes qui vont
devoir décaler leurs départs en retraite
de 1 à 2 ans
quand même la rapidité de la de
l'adoption du télétravail par les
entreprises alors contraintes forcées
mais ils disent tout à l'heure que il y
avait peut-être pas forcément cette
culture chez certains chefs d'entreprise
ils ont pas eu le choix quoi oui alors
ils sont pas eu le choix le confinement
en 2020 a provoqué effectivement
l'organisation autour du télétravail
alors il y a une économiste américain
qui s'appelle David Greber qui a été
importé d'ailleurs par la covid qui
avait écrit juste avant de mourir un
livre qui s'appelait les boules sur les
bullshitjobs les emplois inutiles en
fait et donc il tout un tas d'études aux
États-Unis pour démontrer qu'en fait une
des conséquences du télétravail et ça a
été de mettre en évidence d'identifier
vous avez au bout d'une semaine vous
faites une première réunion zoom et puis
vous vérifiez ce qu'on fait déjà et tout
ça et vous de 15 jours il y a déjà deux
ou trois personnes que vous ne associez
plus la Réunion zoom parce que
finalement vous dites on en a pas besoin
et au bout des 55 jours en France de
télé travail de confinement on peut
considérer qu'il y a les boules ont été
identifiées et donc il y a une relation
nouvelle qui s'organise autour de ça en
fait là aussi Emmanuel Macron ça a été
repris d'ailleurs dans les vœux de
François Hollande les les 2016 de
François Hollande où il disait il va
falloir concevoir la société nouvelle et
qui sera davantage une société client
fournisseur qu'une société employeur
employée et donc la société client
fournisseur c'est la société du
télétravail c'est-à-dire vous vous
organisez comme vous voulez on vous
demande une production résultats un
élément physique possible mais après
vous vous organisez comme vous voulez et
je crois qu'alors là on l'a bien dit
tout le monde ne peut pas être dans
cette situation ce qui a de frappant
c'est que pendant un certain temps on a
été persuadé que les fonctions
intellectuelles étaient préservées par
le fait que la machine pouvait pas les
remplacer puis il y a eu la phase on a
dit mais la machine va aussi remplacer
les fonctions intellectuelles il y a
toute une littérature sur le fait que on
a plus besoin de médecin généraliste on
a plus besoin d'avocat en fait on a
besoin d'une partie très très infime de
toute cette population parce que des
machines vont le faire et donc
finalement les professions
intellectuelles sont ramenées dans le
même degré d'angoisse et dans le même
type de rapport au travail que les
professions manuelles et puis là de
nouveau il y a une distance qui se fait
des professions manuelles sont obligées
d'être sur place les conducteurs de bus
sont obligés d'être présents dans le bus
alors que les professionnels
intellectuels peuvent s'organiser comme
elles l'entendent il y a de nouveau une
inégalité qui est en train de se
constituer dans le rapport au travail
par le télétravail alors travaillez-moi
ça peut venir évidemment d'une volonté
individuelle mais c'est aussi on va le
voir avec il y a un effet qui est juste
derrière le au sens public une volonté
de certaines entreprises bon soir Yann
bienvenue sur sur ce plateau on va
parler de la semaine de quatre jours la
réduction du temps de travail réalité à
l'étranger mais aussi en France on
commence par la France oui ça n'est pas
que le cas des startups c'est le cas de
toutes les entreprises qui vont
apparaître derrière moi par exemple Mozo
le service de pub sur smartphone
également welcome to the jungle une
entreprise de 300 salariés spécialistes
du recrutement même la fonction publique
si mais ça c'est l'URSSAF Picardie qui
l'expérimente le groupe informatique
LDLC lui a fait le choix de la semaine
de quatre jours depuis maintenant deux
ans et écouter son patron vous allez
l'entendre ça n'est pas qu'un cadeau
pour les salariés c'est aussi dans son
intérêt
pour le moment moi j'ai mis la mesure en
place le campus on a réduit le nombre
d'heures je m'attendais à ce que c'est
un coup
et en fait dans les faits ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens
travaillent mieux en 4 jours qui ne
travaillaient avant 5 jours et pour
prendre un chiffre très concret l'année
dernière on a fait 700 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires avec 1050
collaborateurs l'année avant la mise en
place on avait fait 500 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires avec autant de
collaborateurs donc concrètement on a
fait 37% de croissance sans recruter
lui a fait le choix de passer ses 1100
salariés à la semaine de quatre jours
sans allonger les journées ils font
passer des 35 au 32 heures on l'écoute
encore on l'écoute encore c'était la
logistique parce qu'en fait en
logistique en gros il faut à peu près 30
colis à l'heure il faisait en tout cas
30 colliers à l'heure et je m'étais dit
c'est un métier pénible c'est pas un
métier marrant c'est pas parce qu'on
passe à 4 jours et 32 heures qui vont se
mettre à faire pour 35 colis à l'heure
c'est pas possible
et en fait si et c'est même mieux que ça
c'est qu'ils en font plus parce que
comme ils viennent plus reposer comme
ils attaquent des semaines qui dure que
quatre jours qu'ils n'ont pas le temps
en réalité de se fatiguer mentalement
qu'ils ont le temps de se reposer
réellement et ben en réalité ils ont une
meilleure productivité parce qu'ils
arrivent avec le sourire au lieu
d'arriver en se disant bah une semaine
de plus et je les enchaîne sans arrêt et
cette mesure concerne tout le monde les
techniciens les vendeurs les cadres bon
ça a l'air d'être un succès dans les
entreprises qui l'ont mis en oeuvre
est-ce qu'on a une idée de la part des
entreprises pour lesquelles ce système
fonctionne oui Thomas et pour ça il faut
le se rendre au Royaume-Uni le pays
amener la plus grande expérimentation à
jamais réalisé sur le sujet pendant six
mois 61 entreprises on fait passer la
semaine de 5 à 4 jours 2900 salariés
concernés une réduction de 20% du temps
de travail et un salaire maintenu
conclusion de l'étude les effets ont été
très bénéfiques à la fois sur le
bien-être des salariés mais là on avait
assez peu doute mais aussi pour les
entreprises 92% d'entre elles ont
maintenu la semaine de quatre jours
après l'expérimentation leur chiffre
d'affaires n'a pas baissé il a même
légèrement augmenté de 1,4% en moyenne
on connaît les difficultés actuelles des
entreprises à fidéliser leur salarié et
bien le dispositif a permis de diminuer
les départs de 57% et puis les arrêts
maladie ont baissé moins 65% côté
salarié ils sont 39% à se sentir moins
stressé 71% à se dire moins épuisé en
bref du personnel plus en forme plus
épanouie et donc plus productif merci
beaucoup Yann ça va forcément faire
réagir nos invités je vous regarder
pendant la chronique de Yann et Félix le
marin je voudrais d'abord avant de
parler du fond de la semaine de quatre
jours sur le principe de la
l'expérimentation je trouve que c'est
c'est vraiment intéressant tester une
réforme dans un département avant de la
généraliser la France l'a déjà fait
d'ailleurs mais c'est est-ce que c'est
dans notre culture politique ça oui non
c'est pas tellement hein
pour le coup alors le gouvernement
essaye de mettre en oeuvre des
expérimentations mais c'est vrai que la
culture de l'expérimentation et de
l'évaluation c'est à dire de prendre une
loi et de voir un an après deux ans
après 5 ans après ce que ça donne si ça
marche ou pas éventuellement ajuster
c'est pas tellement dans notre culture
touristique et il y a plein de secteurs
celui de la sécurité notamment on a
tendance à empiler les lois souvent de
manière émotionnelle en réaction un fait
divers et on sait très bien que du coup
dans l'empilement on est plus capable de
savoir ce qui est efficace qui ce qui ne
l'est pas et que sa nuit forcément
efficacité de l'action publique ça c'est
ça c'est clair habituels sur le principe
de la semaine de quatre jours
j'entendais réagir
aux propos du chef d'entreprise sur la
les effets en termes de productivité
d'état d'esprit des
salariés qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
intéressant d'entendre en plus les
salaires pour avoir leur point de vue
mais effectivement c'est plus dans le
sens de l'histoire que d'essayer de
courir d'avoir une productivité qui
s'effondre et dire on va augmenter le
nombre d'heures le sens de l'histoire au
20e siècle c'est plutôt effectivement
des gains de productivité et du temps
libéré une augmentation du taux d'emploi
parce que les femmes ont davantage
participé au travail mais par contre des
journées qui se raccourcissent des
vacances les 35 heures en France etc
donc c'est plus dans le sens de
l'histoire et ça pose aussi ça c'est
intéressant la question de
l'organisation du travail mais alors
tout à l'heure vous disiez on pourrait
supprimer des jours fériés pour que
finalement à l'époque on période de
notre vie où on est les plus productifs
on travaille on travaille plus donc vous
êtes peut-être pas forcément d'accord
sur le sens de l'histoire ah ben si si
nous sommes d'accord sur le sens de
l'histoire c'est la réduction du temps
de travail je suppose qu'il y a des gain
de productivité l'enjeu c'est d'où
viennent les gains de productivité
c'est-à-dire que encore une fois le le
le grand mystère de ce qui se passe en
supprimer pardon ou alors je comprends
rien mais supprimer des jours fériés
c'est pas c'est pas réduire le temps de
travail au contraire bon au contraire
supprimer des jours fériés par du
principe que les gains de productivité
ne sont pas au rendez-vous donc là dans
l'exemple qu'on a eu c'est quelqu'un qui
dit moi j'ai fait des gains de
productivité j'ai réorganisé
l'entreprise et il y a des gens qui vous
disent mais pourquoi pas la semaine de
quatre jours mais 9 heures par jour donc
ça fait 36 heures au lieu de 35 donc bon
donc il faut bien voir là c'est vraiment
on réduit à 32 heures la durée du temps
de travail et donc le seul commentaire
que fait l'échelle d'entreprise ça a
permis de faire des gains de
productivité alors les gains de
productivité à l'heure actuelle donc les
pays développés dans les pays qui sont à
ce qu'on appelle comment dire
technologique ne sont pas au rendez-vous
alors c'est c'est et donc vouloir
baisser la durée du temps de travail
s'il y a pas les gains de productivité
ça conduit à un échec dans les années 30
on a baissé brutalement le temps de
travail aux 40 heures on a été obligé de
revenir à la Libération là-dessus et
progressivement on a réinstallé la
baisse du temps de travail au fur et à
mesure qui a eu des gains de
productivité donc il faut pas mettre
verser il faut pas mettre la charmé
avant les bœufs il faut d'abord le
progrès technique d'abord l'évolution
technologique et à ce moment-là on
pourra le réduire le temps de travail
alors c'est vrai que sur long terme sous
la monarchie du hi on travaillait un
salarié travaillé 3200 heures par an
aujourd'hui un salarié il travaille 1400
heures par an en France et il vit mieux
et évidemment mieux mais il y a eu du
progrès technique c'est pas c'est pas
une décision comme ça qui est tombée
c'est pas le le gouvernement qui a dit
paf ça va aller mieux non c'est pour
mettre une question entre la valeur du
temps de travail comment on ce temps de
travail parce que c'est plus de la durée
c'est et c'est ce qu'on voit dans dans
le reportage là c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait de ce temps de travail et comment
il est valorisé et a priori dans les
témoignages qu'il y a eu là ça veut dire
qu'il est fortement valorisé même quand
on réduit en heure et ça c'est important
à comprendre parce que c'est pas du tout
la mentalité en effet moi je reviens
là-dessus du management c'est le
management comme vous l'avez dit il a
besoin d'avoir tout le monde en visio
tout le temps c'était ce qui s'est passé
au covid au covid tous les matins les
managers prenaient tout le monde en
visio ce qui était totalement inefficace
mais juste pour vérifier que les gens
étaient bien là parce qu'ils étaient
dans un temps de travail et pas dans une
valeur travailler et c'est ça à mon avis
qui est dur à faire passer en termes de
culture parce qu'on a l'impression que
la personne va aller se baigner toutes
les 5 minutes mais si elle fait bien son
travail en une heure ou deux heures ce
qu'elle faisait habituellement à 8h et
qu'après elle va se baigner il y a aucun
problème et ça on a du mal encore à le
comprendre et à le voir à l'accepter on
termine toujours sur ce thème de
l'organisation du travail vous propose
c'est ces chiffres issus d'une étude de
l'Institut Montaigne 35% des qui disent
travailler souvent ou toujours le
week-end le soir après 20h et jour férié
face à cette tendance il y a un
mouvement je sais pas s'il est vraiment
nouveau mais en tout cas il est décrit
comme tel notamment aux États-Unis qu'on
appelle le Koweït quicking ou démission
silencieuse écoutez les explications de
cette coach en développement personnel
the croyauting ou silent cuisination ou
silent sur
la démission silencieuse et ça consiste
en quoi et bah tu restes dans le poste
tu fais ton travail professionnel mais
tu refuses les heures supplémentaires tu
refuses de répondre aux emails ou au
téléphone en dehors des horaires de
travail et tu refuses d'assumer des
responsabilités qui ne font pas partie
de la description de ton poste toute
l'ambition de ce mouvement c'est de dire
non au stress et oui à la santé mentale
au travail pour bien distinguer vie
perso et vie professionnelle
Michael Zemmour les mots santé mentale
au travail j'ai l'impression que c'était
totalement tabou il y a quelques années
et qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est dans le
vocabulaire de tous les DRH oui donc là
on peut dire que c'est un progrès c'est
un progrès ou c'est la reconnaissance
d'un problème oui aussi mais ce qu'elle
décrit en partie ça s'appelle la le
respect du droit du travail c'est à dire
ne pas travailler en dehors de ces
heures de travail ne pas prendre des
responsabilités si elles sont pas
reconnues dans la fiche de poste le
droit à la déconnexion ça fait partie
des droits du travail effectivement il y
a pu y avoir des cultures
professionnelles qui disaient la mission
est plus importante que le droit du
travail on va s'asseoir dessus mais tout
à l'heure on disait il y a des choses
qui dépendent des entreprises les
pouvoirs publics ont une responsabilité
aussi au moins à deux titres d'abord en
tant qu'employeur il y a une personne
sur cinq dans ce pays qui travaille pour
une organisation publique et
fonctionnaire etc et en tant
qu'employeur à la fois sur les
rémunérations et sur l'organisation du
travail l'État est loin d'être
exemplaire vous parliez des internes
mais c'est vrai aussi dans l'éducation
ou dans plein de secteurs du public donc
il y a une responsabilité du public de
ce côté là et puis il y a aussi des
institutions la médecine du travail
parce que santé mentale au travail s'il
y a pas de médecins du travail c'est un
voeux pieux donc la médecine du travail
l'inspection du travail aussi qui fait
en sorte que la réglementation soit
appliquée donc évidemment l'organisation
du travail ça c'est dans les entreprises
mais il y a besoin d'un cadre
institutionnel et qui aujourd'hui est
plutôt détricotée que qu'on se l'idée
vous allez travailler quatre ans à
Matignon comme conseillère du de Premier
ministre les politiques ou les
conseillers les conseillers qui sont
souvent accro au boulot et ce qu'ils
peuvent comprendre les Français qui bon
voilà soit enfin veulent faire le
minimum ou alors sont dans comme vous le
disiez le respect tout simplement du
travail c'est sûr que c'est une question
de culture là aussi
c'est c'est très éloigné de de
cet exemple là de respect absolu enfin
en gros de toute façon quand vous êtes
en cabinet vous savez qu'il y a pas de
droit du travail qui s'applique en vrai
donc vous pouvez être en fait on dirait
du jour au lendemain et vous savez à
toutes les questions de même de
harcèlement etc elles sont pas traités
de la même manière que dans le reste de
la société donc forcément oui j'imagine
que la manière dont les uns et les
autres du coup perçoivent la société est
un peu biaisé et ça explique sans doute
que
le monde politique finalement intègre
difficilement et avec retard les
phénomènes que les entreprises
connaissent
très vite on parlait de Burnout le monde
politique a mis beaucoup de temps à
s'emparer de ce sujet même la semaine de
quatre jours
ils y arrivent un peu sur la pointe des
pieds mais mais c'est quand même pas un
truc enfin on n'a pas inventé un la
martingale quoi c'est ça pourrait être
quelque chose qui est porté par
différentes responsables politiques on
voit bien que
ben non en fait
ils hésitent je pense parce que
il y a quand même dans la partie de la
classe politique la peur et notamment au
centre et à droite la peur d'être rangé
dans la case
ceux qui encouragent les assister les
paresseux etc et donc et donc
l'innovation politique et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs de tous les sujets
aujourd'hui le monde politique peine à
produire de nouvelles idées de nouvelles
solutions et finalement est plus ou
moins la remorque de la société qu'à
l'initiative de changement réel et
profond en gros les politiques ils vont
les chercher dans le monde de
l'entreprise dans le monde associatif
ils vont s'inspirer d'idées mais ils en
sont pas les initiateurs ils en
produisent de moins en moins en quelque
sorte merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débattement je
rappelle le titre de votre livre on aura
tout essayé livre publié aux éditions
Fay